[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja
besser
sagt ein
bild davon verschaffen wir nicht
aufpassen und sich dass mir die zweite
heimat wirklich sein
ja immer wieder da
vor 20 jahren und ich mag sie
einen dokumentarfilm über den
schulkosten zürich 14
du bist mir schnell aufgefallen mit dem
wilden offen
doch habe ich meinen augen auch
unsicherheit
verletzlichkeit und dann innere komme
ich ans gefühl du bist auf die suche
nach zugehörigkeit und als kämpfer kam
mit dem sich fremd fühlen ihr eigenheim
noch ein filmprojekt hat kontakt zu tee
verlogen du hast du schon bei geht
locker schwierige zukunft
zwölf jahre sind vergangen bis max
du hast dich geht sieht für kriminelle
kollegen entscheiden und bewaffnetem
raub knapp vorsorge büro
ich bin aufmerksam wurden diverse
zeitungsartikel über die klasse hatte
apple knapp
du hast dich verändert ich hoffe du hast
also therapie gemacht eine ausbildung
zum hoch du hast ihn geschrieben und im
rat eines werkzeugs 100 zum verarbeiten
als mittel zur reflexion
du hast die gesetz für geförderte
jugendliche aus vier seminaren und
workshops sky sie hat die zu große und
wartet bis keine
belgischen ort sozialarbeiter von der
straße
[Musik]
während einige zeit im krankenhaus hat
schweiz ist im fruchtwechsel initiativen
augen jetzt bist du aber nicht wirklich
jedem moment ausgeschafft werden
das herkunftsland der kosovo und das
obwohl das baby der schweiz land
[Musik]
die
gäste
und von beeskow das heißt bevor
ja ich muss ein bisschen schauen aber
muss ich mich gewaltig jetzt mal schauen
was das bundesgericht entscheiden
kann man nicht sagen
ja
ja so lange bin ich glaube schon
ich kann viel geben du siehst es auch
bei den jugendlichen abkommen das ist
das was ich mir region waren
mein vorteil von trento menschen eine
chance geben werden unser etat ist
schwer gehabt wir könnten uns nicht wie
beim motorrad ist kein arzt oder kein
jurist dass er mir was hilft und dass
ich weiterkomme bei uns ist sehr schwer
und ich denke solche menschen folgt man
einen
und ich denke mal das konzert
[Musik]
das ich selber schuld bin mieter sind
mit luzern schuldiger suche nach hus
rede ich wie der schuldige man ehrlich
bin nicht lustig sie was man so macht
ist in japan sieht für ein hochwasser
forscher über hof ihr bin ich schon drin
und da ist sie immer noch
[Musik]
interessiert darum verstehe mich wollen
wir die jetzt größer konstatiert
ist es leider so dass das manche doch
noch andere frau geschwister
wieso erst jetzt mal gesprungen
sie müssen fortgesetzt
[Musik]
ich bin es tor wurde klose von
jugendlichen somit verwundert warum
lautet raus und jedermann schule jetzt
dank dass ich darauf nicht versagt hat
und das ich bin schon viermal so oft er
kann was passiert ist bisher schuldig
[Musik]
aber ich kann auch die probleme zum
danach
etwas mal artig halblinks millimeter
dass sie mich so wohl nicht zusammen
schießt wie soll ich jetzt schon zwei
drei wochen
geschaltete schwierig
aber ich bin herzlich willkommen egal ob
vom prinzen oder familie oder andere
nachbar wieder mit trotz
[Musik]
schwierig
[Applaus]
ich
weiß
nicht ich mit viel aus
[Musik]
die jugend von hyper-v
haus wo eine rolle die die schweiz
gehört mir und das bevor das alles
passiert ist standort oder linear zürich
ich kann schon bessere situation
etwas zu ändern
heißen
was ich integriere
hochstamm morgen über schaufeln
das ist integration von man das sind
manche machen das ist mein bisher ein
gut
fehler gehören zum leben und ich bin so
auch ein integrierter macht verliert
also besser gesagt ein schweizer
nur wenig fehler gemacht und ich bin ein
integrierter in der schweiz
[Musik]
man sich integration in die schweiz
man weiß ja gar nicht war man jetzt ein
schweizer die showbühne das geht so
verschieden
naja das ist klar sehr viel gespielt das
problem
also das was gefangen es gibt
dann deshalb waren spieler und
einmal das ist fakt und dann wurde ich
schulde kam
und dann waren kredite dir sage dies
galt nicht als problem
die solon se
vorsteht sieht aber noch einer sagen
immer das problem
und bevor die familienprobleme
[Musik]
schlussminute situationen ist mit der
bestellung
straße
statt
aber es hat mich gefreut dass ich damals
verhaftet worden
doch
es wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann die seite ganz bindungslos zum mord
zu fordern das heißt sehr kreativ 30 uhr
ort nämlich mit allen schöne negative
titel natürlich und verloren bei der
führungsposition
[Musik]
dass die beiden in frage bejaht damit
hier die beiträge fürchten
[Applaus]
so probierte sie sind in einigen
[Musik]
orten geboten
du hast jackie clare
hannover gemeinsam slawen entschieden
gesund war
das was du daraus machst du dir schon
immer gewünscht hat ich zum griff nach
einer ecke die familie
[Musik]
wolf dort besteht schweiz
frankreich stück schafft und
gleichzeitig als gewinn
sie hat fast sie kaufe dir so bestimmt
zweite laden sollen plötzlich im zürcher
oberland
[Musik]
die ganzjährige münchen gruppe behaupten
schmidt frage familie im osthessischen
schweizer familie
gelebt als kind sehen viel lieber drum
disziplin
ausstand
danke bitte
ich glaube
das sieht mir ein richtiger schweizer
sie wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr
schweizer als viele schweizer was aber
sind
die erste schultag ist
viereckig sie nicht
mit verträgen wir so die wom afrika hat
also eigentlich sehr politik
und industrie sind sind alle schweizer
xiii und mira partecke
das hat sie von dort war nicht so heiß
vier zugaben ich möchte zum verhängnis
wurde sagen wir's oder schweizer 7
im schweizer team ja schweizer und ich
bin ein spiel
bis zum siebten lebensjahr bin ich mit
einem freund von xi
aber der kontakt nicht das
sind für mich immer nur
emotional die sehr starke bezugsperson
und
[Musik]
was wehtut dem ganze
irgendwann hätte ich hier zum in ihrer
lieblingsserie oder mir egal oder
für mich ist klar xi und auf die
plattform illi und ein familiäres klagen
sind dass das nicht ewig
das wetter hat oder was passiert ist wir
ich kann da bin verriet auf morgen das
in kontakt und dann hat man immer
schlacht das sind wir über die rhv
erzählt und ich bin immer sich sagen
dass das alles nicht stimmt und wie soll
man sich jetzt innerhalb
der tischmitte
stiftung ist ein dioxin professionelle
dir das ist
kriminell
also ich hab das alles miterlebt und war
für die hand dreht oder die hamburger
die honeycomb und drogerie heike und
alles die hosen machen in der krise
niemand
das klappt spanne jetzt bitte die
familie hast du so vollgestellt glaube
ich war alles wurde der glaube ist
kriminell
das ist glaube wichtig war die antwort
wird alles fernbusse krimi nicht
in die familie etwas zurück
[Musik]
lesen nämlich laut
das mit windel kartoffel der schweiz wo
ist deine kinder gottes heute schwingt
fassungen auto auch in der schweiz
verwandten familie leben alle in der
schweiz freundinnen und freunde kennen
erklärt der schweiz spielt man diese
sprache dir spricht in der schweiz die
kriminellen taten die begonnen die
strafe für die taten sasse rapide steigt
und wollte sich gerne lieber statt
eine chance verdient
zwei jahre nach dem musikvideo als
bundesgericht endgültig entschieden die
ruhstorfer das herkunftsland und
wie den boden und
die heimat ist der beschriebene landwirt
ohne kranz
die frau und du hast trennt den größten
traum von der eigenen familie und dem
erleben in der schweiz
juli die strunde programm bild ist
rentner und
trotzdem bösch positiv und
kämpferisch zuversicht und
selbstbewusstsein
damit um nicht schafft schafft
[Musik]
stoffe.de job verdienen wird
wenn man das jetzt über leid was
eigentlich der unterschied nicht
schaffen
sie aus
der drehung bestimmt links sind die
bizarre kauften ihm erzählte wochen
stimmt job kam
es zu beschützen
und china die
richtige strafe mit dem schaffen
das hat man also alles was passiert
hatten und irgendwann zeigt sich
positiv
[Musik]
die sache büro ja
und ich sage es jetzt noch fix jahr
nochmal ich bereue gar nicht ich würde
mich nur fertig gemacht zusammen und ich
bin das einzige was ich bereue
ich habe den schmerz und ich eigentlich
zurückführt dann sechs tropfen oder oder
in einer familie
russland in der pflicht der abi gemacht
anfang ist
was ich von einem trend an und das ist
empathie
sich ein anderes versetzen versuche
fielen während sich gekannt
[Musik]
so schweben isoliert
aber ich wollte
ja
[Musik]
einher und lassen
herzlich willkommen
er schreibe die
momente
der nun die nato das
war schon
2017 vor zwei wochen haben wir da
gestartet mit dem aufbau von call center
mobile öffnet sich um zwei reporter
formieren
ich für euch nach nummer ganz ändern
dass dann
das ist live session
drummer sie als chefin der ganze bereich
da haben wir einen schilling
und soll bis nicht gar nicht gern
oder der mitarbeiter von mir
aus dem bereich kundenservice
von verschiedenen firmen wo es sehr gut
läuft ich bin mir sicher wir sind heißt
führerscheinstelle ganz schön stark als
in größeren
übrigens in die zahnpasta
also ich es für besser
vorsorgen der chef
der lehrer nicht aber sie
muss ja auch nicht telefonieren
ja
alle helfen mit
mussin wählerschaft
elf monate größere
das schönste an der firma
das ist
das sogenannte konferenz runde
danielzik planung investiert und das ist
die
neue welt geplant
ist
ich bin unter druck sehr
große verantwortung mit dem
gefühl sagt mir dass
das erfolgreich sie wird
ist ihnen bewusst raum noch besser
verzeichnet und
will
ich gern planen
ich bin haben suchen immer noch
lehrstellen aber
reichlich spät angefangen sind schon
viele
verschnupft und
ich hoffe dass ich eine lehrstelle
finden so fahrzeiten eine lehre
absolvieren
und die die gäste mit das
ist aber auch schon bestiegen ich weiß
es wird schwierig aber meine sms
kommt das komplette mannschaft
das heißt 15
ja schon
[Musik]
15 vergangenheit
dann gelangen
und das führt wieder verdammt schwer
doch seinen 12 tag
ich freue mich ja das ist ja schon
wieder war von zwei wochen
das ist sicher
ein selbsttest wie schon wieso mich ja
ich habe positiv erstellt wurden das
heißt ich liebe und das heißt nach macht
wird im zwei tage im werk standen und
internet
[Musik]
ein job in
der nacht vom 11
so wurden vom dank lieber stand jetzt
aber gebe wenig schlossen in der schweiz
aber für mich ist die heide
statt
oder eine muschel auf
[Musik]
das hier und schon hast und wie kommt
das
aber was soll's
geschafft
alles läuft gut
das wieder wenden
er war durch
[Musik]
schuldig
ich verhandle
fasching
dass ich einmal auf einen job im
callcenter
unternehmenskonzepten dennoch nicht dass
beim kolleg
erzählt dass man da
wirklich schafft raum achern mit dem
content award verliehen
das potenzial hat und dann
nicht die nähe folge
so bis zu eröffnen
[Musik]
finanzielle mittel
ersparen
so
war das konzert findet und das
geschäft ist der schweiz
die man eigentlich kommt
darf man das
der notdienst
ja will
ich liebe das
[Musik]
und worden war ich mit dem kontakt mit
tampons freigestellt
investor interessiert eigentlich galt
wurden erstellt hat und noch ein ass in
dieser partie
das heißt doch was ich mache wird gut
spanien schweiz
also ich sowieso nur
papier
das lohnt sich
ja aber lockt das
zumutbar weil ich das nicht ich habe mir
ein businessplan ist ein investor findet
das ist
wann machst dann richtig und es ist mit
so viel geld wie dem schloss 2 user
machen
[Musik]
information
wiedersehen
ich finde es jetzt sogar
[Musik]
es werde
naja
[Musik]
ein rucksack
ich weiß zwar was hat dieser
politik
was man sich
[Musik]
dann gibt's nicht
mussten
[Musik]
jetzt besuchen
zweimal die zwei wochen der torlinie
flow hat zehn monaten liegen wir runter
und sie darf man so sind immer gesagt
dass
wir nachts war
das nicht
[Musik]
auch über eine jahr im kosovo ist es so
wie
du hast spezial wiso mein büro und darf
für zwölf tage zurück in die heimat
[Musik]
wichtig ist mir einfach passiert
somit kann das setup ist für immer weg
[Musik]
meine heimat
ich meine damen und herren
das ist ja alles schon vor seiner geburt
museen das heißt
muss man nicht vorwerfen
dass ich die falsche kabine
so kann
[Musik]
es nach der torte geboren der stand noch
nicht ahnt was das heißt sie
[Musik]
50 minuten
soll heißen wir rufen ich ja er wird
als mittlerweile
zwei jahren hatte mich einmal eine hatte
mich weit kommt und eine halbjahres so
oft am ende nur per telefon
der ich bin gespannt wer reagieren wird
habe mich nur erkannt
und wir so fasst
[Musik]
ich freue mich sie zu nehmen
dank der guten beziehungen und
versuchen
sehr schwierig
sein sollen braucht sind
[Musik]
dies wie diese mit dem sohn hunter
befinden ich habe mich mehrmals gefragt
wirst sie ist mit dem sohn wie es für
dich sie ist ist ihr gott
[Musik]
du bist meine fragen ausgewichen und
sehr still sie
jetzt bist mir vor wie ihr beruf der
flucht und asyl einzel grand
[Musik]
nachdem du zurück in kosovo gebüsch uni
witten/herdecke
ramsauer gemacht
und bin gleichzeitig irritiert sie will
domina auch rechte hergibt ist
nach anderthalb jahre heute vor dir
woher man erzählt dass du aus wie die
spezial visum
überraschend tage zieht postfiliale in
tutow für bevor
bestückt fällig wurde und wieder hat
kriminalität
es ist nett land gerne und ich habe mich
frage warum du das gemacht hat
warum
[Musik]
du hättest doch eigentlich nur noch
knapp zwei jahren
[Musik]
ob ich das machen was machen dann bei
uns getankt das sind interessante wo man
sich interessiert das callcenter wir
sind immer wieder hohe berge oder
der job von job gesucht an und dann habe
ich erzählt was mir machen die stars und
dann hat seit jahren
seit jahren der schutzfrist und so und
dann ist
der stabilität
nach einseitig für kaffee trinke
gern noch geblieben und alles verstehen
und im internet machen
ich muss eine andere inhalte sehen
durch eine politisch daran erklären in
kosovo
das sind die nicht er hat mir hier
geschaffen
und ich bin zudem ist übergang man immer
etwas los ist das so und so und träumen
kann niemanden kannte man das auto
müsste man
dann nicht mehr an die macht ich mach da
das weiß ich jetzt mit der zeit machen
oder so aber
ich möchte einfach in ruhe weiter machen
dann sagt mir der polizist dass die
eigentlich macht uns kollidiert sind
es ist zwar faktisch
wieder bedroht wurde
ich habe zurück droht
sondern es mit wird das ist eigentlich
alles gut und dann ist ein satz gefallen
aber hätte nämlich sofort
sind dann wieder auf den kinos
und dann ist so eine schlägerei vor und
die spermaspuren unter dir nicht
richtiger sowie einen markt kann mich
erholen
und dann sind die zwei arten von der
mtvs sind so zwei kreisstraßen sind kein
tv-gerät und deren verteilung das wisse
auto nach links schwarzer nachts dann
ist man stoff gang und anna tschirner
gekriegt
sehen was die kinder konnten
die kinder dann kommt eine versteckte
neigen immer verloren zurück zu sein
[Musik]
november geschlossen
aber ich glaube
richtig luft schossen
nicht inaktiv
wir
regieren immer nur die dorfältesten
das ist das alte testament oder das land
technik wo die dorfältesten sich bald
die versionen angehört und dann bis
festsetzt und bei mir ist es aussehen
das ist ein ganz toller und zwei jahren
große vor
dass die ihre macht wieder
repräsentieren das ich schon sagen ob er
jetzt hat er seine widerstand macht es
sind so mächtig dass der mann sich jetzt
mental
und ganz alt hat
und ein anderer geführt und
jetzt erlebt sie
zählt
zur wirtschaft ist weder mit dem
heutigen urteil
das bezirksgericht uster in china
rechtlicher hinsicht
rechtlicher würdigung vor der
staatsanwaltschaft vollumfänglich
gefolgt was strafmaß abend lang haben
sich über 50 männer betreut 51
verurteilung stehen sieben jetzt friede
was landesmusikrat 13 motive aber dass
man auch erfahren dass rechtliche
würdigung praktischen vorteilen vorhang
gründig
bedeutung der musik
wir haben die geschichte versucht aber
mit der kantonspolizei zürich zwei
offiziere haben dadurch mehr als 5 grad
ost stimmt das so nicht stimmt und somit
liga mitte geflankt
so kraus sein
kann man das damals tätowierer und
da das licht schatten und sohn gestern
und da das lied und das eben etwas nicht
mitmachen
jetzt gesehen worden
schließlich nicht schuld dass ich mit
meinem industrie ich habe mich
entschieden das machen ich bin wieder
bei ihnen ist verantwortlich denen
man macht man macht der obmann der
unmöglichkeit zumal lehrer machen
mein kampf so fest und erreicht man so
vieles wenn ich das mache ich
gezeigt dass ich manche anrechnen dann
wird man einfach die schule in
erschienen heißt kann wo es illegal
herkunftsland
sie sind selber schuld dass sie keinen
schweizer pass gemacht hat muss ich mir
alles verbrannt
aber schon das konzept passen
damit auch die bühne
natürlich müsse in der schweiz gemeint
sei der heiligen sich nicht schützen
ich glaube das muss ich mehr automatisch
runden
[Musik]
aber
dann muss ich
finde mich einfach nicht so schnell auf
[Musik]